i literally was like i'm auditioning for
x factor because i will marry harry
styles
camila cabello reveals the real reason
she auditioned for x factor and spoiler
alert she did it all for harry styles
that's the first time i've ever
confessed the real intention behind me
auditioning for x-factor the 25-year-old
singer stopped by the late late show
with james gordon on monday and took a
ride around town for a new installment
of carpool karaoke
[Music]
james hit camilla with the hard-hitting
questions like why did she audition for
x factor back in 2012 instead of the
voice
well her answer was about as candid as
it gets
i was 15 i was like a huge one direction
fan
um
and i was like the voice
x factor and i was like well
one direction will be at x factor i
don't know if they'll be at the boy so
let me audition for x factor that was
the reason literally
[Music]
this is really embarrassing and i can
only say this because obviously that was
like 10 to 10 years ago but i literally
was like i'm auditioning for x factor
because i will marry hairstyles like i
will and
yeah i really believed that of course
harry auditioned for the uk version of
the show two years earlier in 2010.
isn't she lovely
isn't she one
he was later paired up with a few other
contestants zayn malik louis tomlinson
liam payne and niall horan to form one
direction
[Music]
so camila's logic seems pretty legit to
me i was like i'm gonna audition for x
factor we're gonna meet
i'm gonna become a singer and we'll
probably fall in love right sounds about
right thank you very much
the cuban american singer's new album
familia dropped on april 8th and
features a collab with ed sheeran titled
bombbomb
[Music]
he is like
my
dream feature collaborator
um and so when i sent him the song he
was like oh i love it let's definitely
do this i just felt like this is too
good to be true he's going to change his
mind and he didn't and he's been so
excited about it throughout but whose
music does she like more harry's or eds
oh my god
thanks to james corden and a little
carpool karaoke lie detector test we got
our answer
whose music do you prefer harry's or eds
that's true
i do love harry's music too though but
you know and while camila's grand plan
to marry harry didn't pan out she did go
on to date shawn mendes
i love him
in
uh he's my boyfriend way but i've always
loved him as just i just love him you
know the two announced their split in
november and according to camila some
new suitors have already shown interest
has anyone verified
slid into your dms
yes
true
[Music]
but has she slid into anyone's dms
i mean if you've got to think about it i
know it's not as simple as a yes from
now on i'll say i'll say
i'll say
okay i'll say no
i'll say no on a technicality
that's a lie okay
and when eti chatted with the havana
singer last month she said she channeled
her heartbreak into her new music
specifically bombbomb i started writing
this song a few months back and uh so we
had this kind of chorus idea
about just kind of like what it's been
like in my late teens and early 20s kind
of kind of falling in it in and out of
love and the ups and downs of that
and also reminding
myself
as my mom has told me
in real life many times that
that's life you're on the ground crying
in the bathroom floor and then you'll
have feelings for another person again
and then you'll be crying on the
bathroom floor again
and
that is kind of like the cycles of of
change like things just change you never
know what's around the corner
[Music]